thank you to the
turning this talk and
of it and thank you to Yale for hosting
this event and for educating me as you
heard i am in fact a an alum and finally
I'd like to give a very special thank
you to James Snead a professor of
literature here at Yale he taught me in
three courses and I can assure you not
one of them was a gut there was a very
rigorous survey of the Western literary
canon a seminar on William Faulkner and
another seminar on James Joyce and Tomas
Mon that Professor Sneed or Jamie as he
was known to his friends was
incandescent when I was here he was one
of the only african-american professors
at Yale he was a concert level jazz and
classical pianist he was a novelist and
despite all of these and many other
attributes I'm almost certain that none
of you know him or even heard of him and
there's a reason for that James need
died 22 years ago at age 35 of AIDS HIV
is scientifically classified as a
lentivirus literally a slow virus an
untreated HIV takes about 10 years to
kill patients and it also spreads much
more sluggish lead and say measles or
the flu even South Africa which suffered
a veritable HIV blitzkrieg it took HIV
about 10 years to saturate the South
African population the AIDS epidemic
first discovered 30 years ago among five
homosexual men in Los Angeles rolls
through the world in decades and it is
from that perspective that control of
this epidemic is finally in sight for
the first time ever we have the tools to
gain the upper hand on HIV and to
constrict the torrent of new infections
to a trickle we have the public health
tools to do this in Africa where AIDS is
at its worst
in effect we can transform aids into a
manageable health product for a problem
ending it as an epidemic let me just
repeat that we can end aids as an
epidemic we can do that now with the
tools we already have yes an AIDS
vaccine is absolutely important and it
will be the ultimate weapon it will
perhaps in fact even probably allow us
to eradicate HIV from the planet but we
do not have to wait the years or
possibly decades until we have a vaccine
we have the tools now and every day that
the world delay is deploying these tools
the epidemic swells and so it becomes
harder and more expensive to gain
control of the epidemic and yet I find
or have found that many people who work
in HIV do not fully grasp the
astonishing opportunity that science has
granted to us and so I'd like to explain
this revolution and in so doing I'd like
to discuss at least a little bit the
interplay between research journalism
and activism a little bit of history
back in nineteen eighty nine when
Professor Sneed died there were very few
drugs approved to treat AIDS and they
were useless as most of you know HIV is
very mutable so it can easily evolve to
escape one or even two of the drugs the
drugs by the way are called
antiretroviral drugs in 1996 a decade
and a half into the epidemic researchers
proved that a cocktail of three
antiretroviral drugs put up such a high
barrier that HIV could rarely mutate to
become drug resistance those three drug
cocktails did not end do not cure AIDS
but they paralyze the virus and stop its
destruction of the immune system so
starting from 1996 decorates in rich
countries plummeted and over the last
several years because of an
unprecedented effort led
by activists many of whom have HIV
themselves those life-saving drugs are
finally reaching Africa according to UN
estimates about 34 million people around
the world are living with HIV of those
roughly two-thirds or 22.5 million--
live in sub-saharan Africa of those 22.5
million Africans more than ten point six
million need treatment now and that
means that the disease in their body has
progressed to the point where they meet
the World Health Organization
requirements or guidelines for treatment
and for most of those ten point six
million the virus has weakened their
immune system to the point where they
are in imminent danger of acquiring TV
or some other opportunistic infection
that will kill them so of those 10.6
million treatment people who need
treatment now how many are getting it
unfortunately the UN estimates only go
through 2009 so I did some
back-of-the-envelope very rough
calculations or extrapolations and i
would say that today somewhere between
five and a half and six and a half
million Africans probably have access to
HIV treatment this is clearly not enough
10.6 million needed but it is a
jaw-dropping just a jaw-dropping
achievement I remember back in 1996 when
the world aids conference was held in
Vancouver and a prominent researcher
held up a glass of water and said if
this were the cure for AIDS no one in
Africa would ever get it his comment
shows that what experts once thought was
impossible can be possible and in fact
day is a fact on the ground but despite
all of the progress one fundamental
problem has stubbornly refused to go
away more people get infected with HIV
then die of AIDS so the epidemic
continued
to grow in 2009 again the most recent
year for which there are statistics 2.6
million people worldwide contracted HIV
in sub-saharan Africa 1.8 million got
HIV you while 1.3 million died so the
total number of people with Africa told
number of people with HIV in Africa grew
by half a million now each one of those
people of course represents a tragedy
anguish grief the shame that often
accompany is unfortunately getting HIV
because it's a sexually spread disease
but those patients also represent money
the more people who get infected the
more money Africa will need to treat
them and remember if no one else ever
got infected with HIV in Africa we would
still need to more than triple the
number of people in Africa on treatment
because at most a little under seven
million Africans are on antiretrovirals
but at least 20 2.5 million people
already have HIV if Africa cannot
dramatically shrink the number of new
infections the United States and other
wealthy countries that are subsidizing
treatment for Africa are likely to see
AIDS is an intractable insoluble problem
a hopeless money drain and they are
likely to cut back their already
precarious funding that's especially
likely in our current economic and
political climate now it's true that
rates of new infections in many African
countries are leveling off or dropping
but even so far too many Africans are
still getting infected and the plain
fact is that until very recently our
prevention tools for adults were the
same as they were when I was at Yale
taking courses from professors need say
for sex education now such education and
all the behavioral prevention programs
that go with it are crucial without them
the epidemic would be
imaginably worse they must be continued
they must be intensified but the
definition of insanity is doing the same
thing and expecting different results
and it is insane to think that in an
impoverished region where women often do
not have the power to control sex where
a host of factors such as other STDs and
other infections increase the likelihood
that a person will contract HIV that
continuing with the same behavioral
infections will curtail the epidemic it
will not that's especially true for a
simple and wonderful fact the AIDS drugs
which are now flowing into Africa keep
people alive so the number of people who
are dying of AIDS thank God is
diminishing and that means the
prevention has to be better than it ever
has been to bring the number of newly
infected people down below the number of
deaths behavioral interventions are
necessary but they are not sufficient
fortunately we have new tools I'll
discuss what I think are the three most
important tools for Africa the first is
male circumcision and circumcision cuts
to pardon the pun the risk that a man
will acquire HIV by about two-thirds the
results of the first-ever randomized
controlled clinical trial of male
circumcision on HIV acquisition which
was conducted by trono ver in orange
farm south africa were first reported in
that well-known peer-reviewed scientific
journal The Wall Street Journal I had
managed to obtain a copy of the
manuscript with all the data and my
colleagues and I broke the news of what
I still consider to be one of the most
important clinical trials in history of
HIV and we ran the story because the
trial was good science if that study had
been observational if it hadn't been
randomized if the results didn't achieve
statistical significance we wouldn't
have bothered reporting on it especially
because I was on vacation at the time
that I got this manuscript in an
epidemic political leadership is
important money is important culture is
important activism is important and good
journalists write about all of it but at
its core and epidemic is a scientific
problem research matters what you do at
the Yale School of Public Health what
you do at the Center for
interdisciplinary research on AIDS
matters dr. o Vera's publication was
followed by two confirmatory studies out
of Kenya and Uganda but despite three
large randomized controlled clinical
trials all showing that circumcision
protects men against HIV almost nothing
is happy yes Kenya has circumsized a
pretty large proportion of its
uncircumcised men but they're almost
alone really a 2009 US government study
looked at fourteen hard-hit African
countries an estimated that circumcision
spent a fifth twenty percent of new
infections that would have incurred by
2025 but to achieve that 39 million
males would need to be circumcised
before the end of 2015 I've not been
able to find someone or an organization
that keeps track of how many African men
have been circumcised to prevent AIDS
but the experts I've spoken to their
back-of-the-envelope calculations are
well less than two million probably at
the most 1 million which is barely 2.5
to five percent of what needs to be done
in those 14 heat countries and in this
case the problem is not money that same
government study estimated that the cost
would peek at only 425 million dollars a
year and then shrink to 125 to continue
the circumcising babies nor is the
problem that African men will not get
circumcised the luo people in Kenya who
traditionally don't circumcise have
flocked to the procedure and recently in
South Africa the king of the Zulus and
other people who do not traditionally
circumcise has urged his tribesmen to
get circumcised many African groups do
circumcised as a rite of passage into
manhood and so because of urban mixing
and labor migration trees with manliness
and many men and women simply prefer the
look I will always remember this Kenyan
man whose circumcision I witnessed in
2007 after the doctor had finished he
looked down and he said look at that
NASA rocket so why haven't more African
men than circumsized and part of the
answer is a lack of political will even
as recently as last year a prominent us
activist told me that he refused to
advocate for circumcision because as a
white American he found it to charge to
recommend that black African men lop off
a part of their penis now look that is a
real issue
but it can be handled with tact humility
and persistence privately US officials
tell me of very delicate negotiations
with African political leaders
negotiations they've had to carry out
virtually alone American officials are
furious that other donor nations have
been slow to pony up and so to help them
in these negotiations of course there
are some African countries that don't
need to wait for some American or some
European or some donor country to advise
them to do something Swaziland with us
support is launching a one-year campaign
to circumcise eighty percent of its men
South Africa Zambia Zimbabwe Rwanda
they're all beginning to ramp up their
efforts but the fact remains that one of
the most powerful and least expensive
interventions one that could prevent
millions of new infections remains
dramatically underutilized so HIV
continues to spread the second new
prevention tool is called 8 micro beside
this is a gel that contains an
antiretroviral drug that women apply to
their vaginas before and after sex in a
study last year led by the
husband-and-wife team of saline and
caricia abdul karim the gel was shown to
reduce the chance a woman would get
infected by thirty nine percent now some
people say thirty-nine percent is a weak
result they're right and there needs to
be a confirmatory study but to me as a
reporter trying to judge the
significance of this trial the history
of AIDS prevention and AIDS research
looms very large micro beside gel is
odorless colorless and tasteless a woman
can use it without her male partner even
knowing and that's crucial because women
have never before had a prevention
method that they alone control one of
the trial sites for this particular
clinical trial was rural Buland Laila
in South Africa's kwazulu-natal province
in that community more than forty four
percent of women have already contracted
HIV when they reach age 20 to 22 that is
the age if I recall correctly when
people graduate from Yale imagine if
more than four in ten graduating Yale
women were infected with HIV by the time
the women in Buland laila reached 24
which is what may be the time you're
getting your masters degree more than
fifty percent are infected and these
statistics are not unusual for southern
Africa women there need a prevention
method that they control or Africa will
not control its epidemic and yet I spoke
with the leader of south africa's main
organization the treatment action
coalition she acknowledged me that the
TAC was so focused on getting treatment
to ill people who desperately needed it
and so short of resources that they
barely had any program for HIV
prevention at all another member of the
TAC wrote an email to me said quote a
bit skeptical the practical consequences
of the microbicides study thirty-nine
percent is barely good enough for
rollout I'm a bit of a micro beside
skeptic partially for scientific reasons
but admittedly also because of being
jaded by the micro beside propaganda
machine several years down the track and
many millions of dollars spent and still
no effective marketable product in sight
end quote and thirty-nine percent is not
a great result
but that's the overall result among
women who reported relatively high
adherence efficacy was fifty four
percent now the micro beside trial was
not the first HIV prevention trial to
show that an antiretroviral drug could
reduce HIV transmission way back in 1994
the AIDS drug AZT was tried to see if it
could prevent mother's from passing the
virus to their babies in the womb and
during childbirth it worked with an
efficacy of about sixty seven percent
today more powerful drugs and optimized
dosing regimens have increased that
efficacy to at least ninety four percent
now the micro beside trial that showed
thirty-nine percent efficacy was the
first ever to show that a micro beside
worked it used what many researchers
consider an unwieldy dosing schedule and
the gel itself may not be the best
delivery method already researchers in
vision of vaginal ring that a woman
would have to insert only once a month
and what's more new research that I've
given my word not to discuss is
unlocking how one might make the drug
more effective at blocking infection now
well guess Yogi Berra said predictions
are difficult especially about the
future but the history of AIDS research
leads me to believe that thirty-nine
percent will be the floor not the
ceiling of micro beside efficacy that
and the desperate need among women for
some level of protection that they
control is why I push to play the micro
beside trial on the front page
accompanied on the web by a video and a
slideshow I believed then and I still
believe now that that study opened up an
entirely new Vista for HIV prevention
finally the single most powerful adult
HIV prevention intervention other than
absolute lifelong abstinence which is
pretty difficult
proven to work this year in a large
randomized clinical trial it was shown
that when an infected person is taking
the three-drug cocktail he or she is
more than ninety six percent less likely
to transmit the virus than a person not
yet on medication ninety-six percent I
mean vaccines often don't reach that
level of efficacy no large randomized
controlled clinical trials ever been
done for condoms and their effect on
preventing HIV but I bet if one were it
would not reach that level of efficacy
it is simply a stunning result that
study also ends the nihilistic and
divisive rivalry between prevention on
the one hand and treatment on the other
what this study led by Myron Cohen
proved is that treatment is prevention
and hence the name for this intervention
treatment as prevention now it will be
expensive to roll out treatment as
prevention and ensuring adherence and
affordable second and third and fourth
line regimens won't be easy but the
activists David Barr pointed out that
treatment as prevention has one
undeniable financial incentive as he
said it's basically free in terms of its
prevention impact because you're
treating people who would need treatment
anyway now I focused on these three
interventions circum session
microbicides gel and treatment as
prevention there are other interventions
and advances which help which we maybe
can discuss afterwards the last point
about these three interventions is that
none of them alone is a panacea think
about treatment as prevention yes it has
a ninety-six percent efficacy if you're
taking the drugs but not everybody with
HIV will get treated the virus can
mutate and become resistant to HIV and
then if you even if you are on the drugs
you are still infectious some patients
just won't take their medication there
is a methamphetamine
epidemic in many of the cities of South
Africa will meth addicts adhere to their
HIV medication finally a person is most
infectious in the months after they
first contract HIV and these highly
infectious newly infected people might
account for anywhere between 10 and 40
percent of new infections now it's
extremely difficult anywhere in the
world but especially in poor regions of
the world to find people who have just
been infected with HIV and if you can't
find them you can't treat them so for
all of these reasons treating people
with HIV probably will not in and of
itself stop the spread of HIV as for
circumcision not every man will get
circumcised and even those who do are
not immune to HIV they're just much less
likely to get HIV similarly not every
year woman will use a microbe aside and
if they do some will still get infected
even with newer and more improved micro
beside products but if all these
interventions were deployed
simultaneously and aggressively and on
top of robust behavioral interventions
then a patchwork could be created that
would give almost everyone at risk a
level of biological protection that they
have never before had men would be
protected by circumcision women by a
microbe aside and both sexes by treating
as many of those people with the virus
as is feasible it's not enough to do
just one one patch is like one
antiretroviral drug it won't do the job
you need to deploy all of them triple
combination therapy triple combination
prevention all three patches to create
this patchwork and with it we can
envision a sharp even radical reduction
in the rate of new in fact
estimates that I've seen range anywhere
from cutting new infections by half to
as much as three quarters and this is
where the slow epidemic idea comes into
play in keeping with the epidemics slow
roll these reductions could build on
themselves over time similar to the way
compound interest builds as fewer and
fewer infected people exist to pass on
the virus the absence of those they
would have infected and still others
that those people in turn would have
infected can compound to result in a
virtuous cycle of ever fewer infections
the self-propagating compound interest
effects only start when reductions and
new infections reach a tipping point and
even then they take years to sit in so
to get the most bang for our buck and
start to end aids as an epidemic we need
to start deploying these tools as soon
as possible and that's especially true
in Africa the epicenter of the epidemic
have focused on Africa but you don't
have to leave the United States to see
an urgent need for these interventions
we have a raging epidemic among African
Americans who make up a little more than
a tenth of the u.s. population but
account for about half of new infections
in the United States and about half of
aids deaths in the United States the
epidemic is especially horrific among
gay black men according to a recent CDC
research rates of infection among gay
black men appear to be skyrocket here in
New Haven a city with a large and
impoverished black community treatment
as prevention has the potential to help
turn the tide on this epidemic a micro
beside could also help especially if it
were proven to work rectally and not
only vaginally in some scientifically we
have the tools to contain the AIDS
epidemic a scientific
that I have tried to trumpet as loudly
as I can now this is the point where
anecdote that scourge of science but
that indispensable tool of journalism
comes into play scientifically the tools
are there but using them in the real
world is just a whole different kettle
of fish for several years I followed a
South African miner and his wife when I
met them years ago they were courting
now they've been married for a few years
from the time I met them the man knew he
was infected but he refused to tell the
woman he wanted her to know and he even
went to elaborate efforts so that she
would find out he arranged for example
to have them both tested together at the
same time and I went with them to the
hospital I was with them when they
received the post-test counseling or
pretest counseling I was with them when
he rolled up his arm to have the blood
drawn and I was with them when the nurse
walked in to say that the hospital had
run out of test kits meanwhile the wife
clearly did not want to be test it she
consistently refused for years in fact I
wondered to this day if she didn't
secretly persuade the nurse to use
running out of test kits as an excuse to
get out of being tested I'll never know
but I'll always wonder now if you don't
get tested you can't get treated and
indeed countries such as Botswana that
offered HIV free HIV treatment often had
trouble getting people to start taking
it and when people start treatment they
sometimes stop it's a dirty little
secret but first line regimens in Africa
are not as good as those in America they
have more side effects and therefore
they cause a higher dropout rate now my
minor never used condoms as is true of
millions of couples throughout the world
but if the woman didn't know her partner
was positive would she have used a
microbe site I don't know
oh but I tend to doubt it another issue
my minor smokes a lot of pot he grows
daha as they call it in South Africa on
his crawl and he drinks copious amounts
of beer but at least like many of his
urban countrymen he does not use
methamphetamines so clearly there is a
lot of operational research for
scientists in this room to do whatever
the obstacles to deploying these new
interventions and there will be
obstacles you need to identify them and
figure out ways to deal with them
because whatever the problems of
implementing these new tools we already
know the consequences of not
implementing them this kind of
operational research may not be as
glamorous as the break through trials
I've discussed but it is crucial and as
for the activists in this room none of
these tools have yet been rolled out at
a sufficient rate to control the
epidemic largely but certainly not only
because money is scarce in the midst of
a global recession money for AIDS and
poor and middle income countries has
fallen Ireland the Netherlands Italy
have all cut black back on their pledges
largely because of the economic crisis
President Obama has so far managed to
hold money for global aids flat but he's
not kept his promise to raise the amount
of money for global aids and
implementing treatment as prevention not
to mention microbicides and circumcision
will require not flat funding but more
money what I'd like to know and what
several teams are now tackling is
whether a massive investment right now
might actually save money over the long
run by shrinking the growth of the
epidemic in reducing the number of
people who would need to be treated if
that turns out to be true that could be
a very powerful incentive we already
have evidence that treating people makes
overall
all economic sense just last week in
plus one there was a study that assessed
the cost of maintaining those people who
are currently on treatment all the way
through 2020 the authors looked at three
economic factors the gains from labor
productivity the deferred medical costs
and the reduced costs of caring for
orphans when you add just those three
together the economic benefits accounted
for at least 81 percent of the cost of
maintaining those people on treatment
and could give a benefit of almost
triple the cost of providing treatment
as the authors put it these results
suggest that the economic benefits of
treatment will substantially offset and
likely exceed program costs within 10
years of investment for a slow epidemic
that's a good investment it may seem
impossible to implement these
interventions but we were once told that
even if the courier were a glass of
water it would be impossible to provide
the impossible is possible and the
impossible is imperative I just keep
thinking about professor Snead who was
snuffed out at age 35 he was as
brilliant as Harold Bloom who also
taught me when I studied here Snead
wrote on everything from the influence
of Schopenhauer in the novels of tomasz
Mon to the racialized meaning of
basketball in American popular culture
he was a leader in his church he's
actually buried in any Piscopo church
and he befriended scores of people
around the world here's what German man
that he met by accident one day wrote
about him German man is named man named
Peter shidler he writes I was about to
hop on the greyhound bus to San
Francisco and this guy who turns out to
be Jamie asked me if I was on the right
one he sat next to me and when we got to
talking he realized I was German
immediately he started speaking German
and we had a great conversation about
German literature literature such as
brushed
others he knew a lot more than I did
when he went for a pee an old white guy
sitting in front of me turned around and
told me to be very careful with the
blacks I should be very suspicious he
warned a black guy talking in a foreign
language can't be any good and sitting
in the first half of the bus is bad
behavior you all remember of course that
blacks used to be forced to sit in the
back of the bus after almost two days on
the bus we made another stop in Rock
Springs Wyoming the bus driver mumbled
something about a 50 minute break or at
least that's what I and even some
American passengers understood but he
must have said 15 minutes because when
we came back the bus was gone with all
our baggage we had to wait two hours for
the next bus and I was more than worry
about all my lost belongings when we
arrived at the bus station in San
Francisco there was Jamie sitting on a
bench with all our baggage waiting for
us in my mind's eye Jamie Snead and all
the other people that HIV has infected
or killed are still waiting they're
waiting quite frankly for us to use what
we finally have to end the AIDS epidemic
AIDS has killed more than 25 million
people and AIDS is not like cancer which
usually kills those who have lived long
lives after all HIV is spread through
sex so almost all of those who died were
like Jamie's need in the prime of their
lives almost every time HIV strikes it
cuts short someone's potential for
brilliance artistry discovery and random
flourishes of generosity like holding
someone's luggage at a bus station we
should use the new tools to end aids as
an epidemic not only because doing so
makes economic sense and might over the
long slow arc of the epidemic save us
money but also
because doing so will prevent the virus
of robbing us from all the current and
future Jamie's needs who are waiting for
a world without the AIDS epidemic thank
you